In the four years.
Four years ago,
I had the type of five foot four.
No, no, I wish I did four years ago.
I was screaming, wasn't I?
Yeah, screaming.
When I left Warner Brothers,
everyone's animated
for years.
Again, it's a mystery, baby.
We got I got some really good news.
Great news with Warner Brothers.
Amazing.
Wish I could tell you, but here it is.
Peter.
I love you, James.
I love you,
David.
Okay.
To the future.
Picture me rollin
What was your meeting with James
Gunn and Peter Safran like?
It's very, very wonderful.
I'm in the house of Warner Brothers and
they like him a lot of stuff I'm doing.
We got a lot of good things going.
11 more months until we get another movie
we're going to have.
Yeah, we'll have Aquaman, which is funny.
I it's the beautiful thing is I,
me and my partner wrote
the first treatment for it,
but it's 55 page treatment
and a lot of it has to deal with,
you know, me talking to the U.N.,
expediting what's going to be happening
with the melting ice caps.
And it's there's no far off galaxy
coming to destroy us.
There's no aliens from another place.
It's really
just the idea of us ruining our planet
and the fact that we all need
to get it together and save save our home.
So it's it's, it's it's fun.
It's gonna be coming out
and this this December.
And then, you know,
I'll always be Aquaman.
The rumors are I'll always be Aquaman.
Anyone coming in and taking
And then there might be
some other characters too.
So. Oh, so we can play.
I can play other things too.
I can be funny and savage and charming
once in a while.
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
Jason Momoa just posted a brave new video
about Aquaman two
in the big DC movies reboot.
The James Gunn is doing.
The reason he's
super excited is because he's working
on a new DC project after Alchemy and two.
So we'll break it all down
because it does sound now like he's
actually going to survive and continue
playing Aquaman in future.
DC rebooted movies.
Like he says, I'll always be Aquaman.
Nobody's going to come and take that,
meaning
they're not going to recast
anyone else's Aquaman,
but also coming back as different
characters too, in the future.
On top of that,
I'll always be playing Aquaman
and then taking, and then
there might be some other characters too.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
James Gunn is getting ready
to announce his full DC Phase
one slate of movies.
Like all the new rebooted movies,
of course
I'll be doing videos for all that stuff.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything
if you can't hear exactly what he's saying
during some of this.
At the beginning of the clip,
he posted this clip at the Warner
Brothers studio lot
where all the executives have offices
like he's just had a meeting
with the new DC powers that be.
The meeting was about this upcoming
new DC project after Aquaman two,
like the new character he's going to play,
he's super psyched
when he says 40 years ago,
at the beginning here,
he's talking about a meeting
that he had with Warner Brothers in 2019
after the first Aquaman movie
came out about their plans for Aquaman
two The Last Kingdom
in the future of Aquaman.
In the movies, just in general,
not only the plans for the future
of the character at the time,
but their larger plans for the movie
version of Crisis on Infinite Earths
and like their ten year plus plan
that they had at that time, which changed
a couple of times between 2019 and 2022.
A couple of versions of that plan
still involved Henry Cavill Superman
coming back and doing Man of Steel two.
That was all before James Gunn
was hired on and they did the big reboot.
He says the energy about from the lot
with the security guards there.
Those are just a regular security guards
that worked a lot to keep crazy people
from getting in.
The Peter that he mentions in the video
is Peter Safran,
James Gunn's producing partner.
He's featured in
some of the behind the scenes videos,
like he produced
James Gunn's Suicide Squad movies.
He's a producer on the Shazam movies
as well.
Now he's also the co-president
of DC Movies with James Gunn.
Peter Safran mostly
just focused with the financial business
side of the movies,
the upcoming DC series.
He's like the number cruncher James Gunn,
who was also mentioned in this video
he mentions.
James is mostly
just focused on the creative side,
coming up with what's
actually going to happen, the story,
who they cast for, all the characters,
like who they're going to cast
for all these rebooted
versions of the characters,
how they're plotting out
the next ten years of DC movies.
Even though James Gunn
said he's just going to reveal DC Phase
one before the end of January,
he's got like ten years
worth of movies planned.
Kevin Feige
did the same thing
because like I talk about DC Phase
one, Marvel, phase one, Marvel, phase two,
phase three, so forth
that covered everything from Iron Man
one through Avengers
Endgame, like the entire Infinity Saga
movies, James Gunn essentially
had to do the same thing
when they hired him to run DC movies.
His new ten year plan takes them through
like their big universe
spanning crisis on Infinite Earths
style movie.
They might not use crisis
as their big endgame level movie.
It might be something else like Blackest
Night or something else really crazy.
There are a lot of big DC events
that they could use for that.
The David that he mentions in the video
is David Zaslav, the new CEO of Warner
Brothers Discovery.
Like the entire company
and the one that everybody's pissed at
for canceling so many movies
and shows recently.
Like if something got canceled by HBO,
Max that You Love
is probably because of David Zaslav.
Last year they were trying to either cut
or write off $3 billion in debt
because of the merger with Discovery.
It was a huge debacle.
That's why the Batgirl movie got canceled.
That's why they passed
on doing the new Batman Animated series
with Bruce Timm and Matt Reeves.
The thing that he can't talk about that
he mentions is the new DC project
he's working on. Probably Lobo related.
It's widely believed
by pretty much everybody on the Internet
now that's been following him
for the last couple of years because of
his earlier post before he became Aquaman.
He talked for a long time about how he
always wanted to play a version of Lobo.
But for whatever reason, several years
ago, Warner Brothers just never got around
to doing the character
in the live action movies.
And then Zack Snyder came on and did
Man of Steel and cast him as Aquaman
during Batman v Superman.
And that pretty much sealed the deal.
And the reason why he's probably so pumped
is because they're saying
that he gets to come back as Aquaman.
Like,
We're not going to fire you is Aquaman.
We're not going to recast the character.
So you can do more Aquaman
in the DC Universe.
But also they're allowing him
to play other characters as well,
which is where Lobo comes in,
and when he comes back as a Lobo,
he'll have so many prosthetics and makeup
CG effects to alter his appearance
that he'll look different enough.
And it won't be
that weird to see him again.
Really good example
this in the Marvel movies,
and they've done this
with several people in the Marvel movies
will be Josh Brolin playing Thanos
like huge, huge character for a long time
in the last ten years of Marvel,
then playing cable in the Deadpool movies
and coming back as cable in live action
Marvel movies.
Kevin Feige said that he felt that
that was totally fine, like
it wasn't going to be weird.
So it's a similar situation with Jason
Momoa coming back as the version of Lobo.
I'm assuming for now
that his new DC project, that he's
all hyped about is its own separate thing,
like his own movie related project,
but it could be tied to one of the new DC
Phase one movies the James
Gunn is getting ready to announce.
He said he's been writing the new
Superman movie with the younger Superman.
Like Superman Year two
is like them doing for the New Superman
what they just did for Robert Pattinson's
Batman, doing a younger version.
That's not an origin story
set early in his career,
and they literally just did that
in the DC animated movies
with Superman Man of Tomorrow.
Like it's a younger year, one year
two kind of Superman.
He literally faces
a Lobo as one of his earliest villains.
Lobo in the comics is more of an anti-hero
type of character who's frequently
an antagonist.
He was featured heavily during Young
Justice in the other animated series,
but they haven't really done him in live
action yet.
His main powers are regeneration
and just incredible strength.
He's super strong
and he can regenerate his entire body
from a single drop of blood,
so he's incredibly hard to kill
and his healing factor works way faster
than Deadpool's and Wolverine's.
They even had a joke about that
during Young Justice,
where like during the post-credits
for all the episodes,
you see this little tiny piece of Lobo,
just like slowly growing into another Lobo
with Jason Momoa posting this video right
now, just the timing of everything
makes it sound like James
Gunn is ready to announce his for DC Phase
one slate of movies.
Like it's happening next week.
He's setting the announce
all the big movie changes
of the new DC movies
before the end of January.
Hopefully he's not going to wait till
like the very last minute of the month.
The only movies that he's not going to be
messing with are Matt Reeves,
the Batman, too, in the Robert Pattinson
Batman movies, all those spin offs
because they're working on some DC series,
like a Batman Penguin series on HBO.
Max, That'll be set in its own universe
probably throughout whatever
trilogy Matt Reeves is working on.
I'm assuming it's going to be a trilogy.
We'll just call it the Bat verse
right now.
And James Gunn isn't messing with Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker two movie,
which is probably going to be the last
Joker movie that he winds up making.
I'm not expecting a third one,
but never say never.
That'll also be set in his own
completely separate universe.
Everything else, like all the other
collective movie universes, mostly
like the Snyder verse, like the DCU,
is what James Gunn is changing.
He says some people will continue.
So like 98% of the universe
will be rebooted,
but like a couple people will survive
on based on previous history.
It sounds like he's going to do
what he did with the previous
Suicide Squad movie
when he did his rebooted Suicide Squad
film like it was a soft reboot,
he acknowledged some of the characters
that came before,
some of the preexisting continuity
and then basically wipe the slate clean
by killing off most of those characters
and then carrying one or two of them
forward.
The Joker now and I actually think it's
a pretty solid idea
is that they make peacemaker
like the psycho pirate type of character
who remember the preexisting
DCU continuity inserts, raving about it,
and nobody believes them.
When we talk about the new DC Phase
one slate of movies, that's probably
only going to include like 3 to 4 movies
that he's talking about announcing.
I'm not expecting him to talk about stuff
that's further out than that,
even though he said
that he has the next ten years mapped out.
Most likely first ones that we'll see like
we're talking about three or four movies
would be the new Superman movie
that we already know about,
a new Wonder Woman movie
with a different actress.
Not Gal Godot, a new Green Lantern movie,
probably Suicide Squad three in
maybe one of the other recast versions
of a Justice League characters movie,
like a new flash movie with a totally
different person playing The Flash.
I'd be really surprised if he announces
Justice League two or Justice
League
Rebirth, whatever he's going to call it.
I think the next Justice League
movie will be like 4 to 5 years out.
But whatever he winds up announcing,
of course, I'll do videos for it,
make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss those videos.
Talk about the Snyder verse.
Click here for my new Zack
Snyder Rebel Moon
Trailer Video for Zack Snyder's
version of a Star Wars movie.
And click here for my new Flash movie
trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
I'll see you guys in the next one!